Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
"Le numérique :
de l'émancipation
"à l'aliénation".
En ces temps
qui accumulent les crises :
crise sanitaire à peine terminée,
conflit dramatique en Europe,
avec la sale guerre russe
en Ukraine,
économie déprimée
et inflation montante,
persistance des inégalités
socioculturelles,
populisme et nationalisme
en quête
de nouveaux territoires...
La liste
de cette conflictualisation
du monde
n'est pas exhaustive.
Eh bien, dans ce cadre-là,
le numérique
reste néanmoins
au coeur de l'actualité,
pas seulement parce que
l'homme le plus riche du monde,
Elon Musk, s'est offert
le tentaculaire réseau
Twitter,
avant de le dépecer
de sa substance humaine,
comme sont en train
de le faire
ses congénères américains
du numérique,
mais aussi parce que
le numérique coche toutes les cases
d'une révolution
à l'enseigne clivée
de grandeur et décadence,
liberté et surveillance,
progrès technologique
et tribalisme des pratiques...
Bref,
la révolution numérique
est à la double enseigne
de l'émancipation
et de l'aliénation,
avec ce que cela comporte
de transformations profondes
de nos sociétés
et d'anomie sociale.
Nous allons chercher à le comprendre
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Daniel Cohen, vous êtes
économiste et directeur
de l'Ecole d'économie de Paris.
Charleyne Biondi,
vous êtes docteur
en sciences économiques.
Jonas Haddad,
vous êtes avocat
et coprésident
de la fondation Concorde.
Margaux Klein,
vous êtes présidente
du fonds Heritages.
La révolution numérique
nous vient des Etats-Unis,
avant de gagner
le reste du monde.
Daniel Cohen, comment vous expliquez
cette première contradiction
économique ?
Il y en a d'autres
qu'on va chercher
à comprendre.
Ses fondateurs avaient
l'ambition initiale de répandre
partout
le progrès social,
la démocratie.
Finalement, ils se sont mués
en redoutables capitalistes
et leurs enseignes
sont devenues
des machines,
si je peux utiliser ce terme,
à hypercash.
-Alors, ce qui est vrai
des fondateurs...
On pense aux fondateurs,
par exemple, de Google,
qui, au départ, étaient inquiets
que leur logiciel de recherche
puisse être perturbé
par des considérations marchandes
et qui sont devenus
en quelques années,
sous l'influence
d'un économiste,
Hal Varian,
des machines à cash.
Tout a été fait à l'inverse
de ce qui était
annoncé,
pour utiliser les données
qu'ils avaient
à leur disposition,
pour générer du cash.
Au-delà du destin
de ces personnages,
toute l'histoire
du numérique
est à cette image.
Dans les années 70,
quand ça commence,
le numérique, Internet,
c'est d'abord
un outil de communication
des chercheurs aux Etats-Unis,
entre les universités.
Les pionniers, je crois,
sont habités
par une idée libertaire,
une idée venue
de la contre-culture
des années 60 :
mettre à la disposition
de la société
des instruments qui allaient
permettre de se débarrasser
de la verticalité,
d'abolir la verticalité du monde,
qui était l'objet
de la critique
de cette contre-culture
des années 60.
Ils pensaient, en effet,
qu'ils allaient créer
un type de société,
telle qu'elle a pu être rêvée
sur les campus américains
ou dans le monde,
à l'image de Mai 68,
à savoir une société
d'un type nouveau, en horizontalité,
plutôt qu'en verticalité,
mais ça ne s'est pas
passé comme ça,
pour plusieurs raisons.
Pour faire court,
en partie du point de vue,
je crois, de ce récit,
parce que,
après la révolution libertaire
des années 60,
on a connu la contre-révolution
conservatrice
des années 80,
qui a continué
par d'autres moyens,
presque opposés
à l'intention initiale
des jeunes des années 60...
Qui a continué
cette désinstitutionnalisation
du monde,
non pas pour créer
un monde d'horizontalité,
mais un monde de mise en compétition
des différents segments
de la société.
L'ambition
d'une société en horizontalité
s'est transformée,
dans les années 80,
en l'ambition d'une société
régie par la compétition.
C'est ce mélange bizarre
d'une aspiration antisystème,
libertaire, d'un côté,
et d'une mise en compétition
générale qui s'organise
avec la contre-révolution
conservatrice des années 80,
dont je crois en partie que
l'esprit des réseaux sociaux,
aujourd'hui,
se nourrit.
Ce que le numérique
fait advenir,
c'est ce composé bizarre
d'une culture antisystème
et, en même temps,
d'une culture
profondément de compétition,
de rivalité.
-Ils étaient
sincèrement généreux
et ils sont devenus
sincèrement mercantiles ?
-On peut le résumer
comme ça.
-Vous acceptez ça.
Margaux Klein,
vous avez créé un fonds.
Ce qui vous a motivée,
au départ,
c'est d'être
sincèrement généreuse
ou mercantile,
donc de gagner de l'argent ?
-Moi, j'ai commencé
dans le numérique en 2015.
Ca fait quelques années,
maintenant.
Je pense que...
Opposer la générosité
et être mercantile...
Déjà, il y a quelque chose
qui ne va pas,
pour moi.
Après, vous parlez
d'entreprises américaines,
pour la plupart,
qui ont des objectifs.
On les connaît.
On les connaissait pas,
à l'époque.
Si on se recentre sur l'Europe...
C'est important de se focaliser
sur des entreprises
européennes, françaises,
qui n'ont pas toujours cet objectif.
Moi, quand j'ai commencé
dans le numérique,
ce n'était pas mercantile.
C'était simplement le cas
de tous les jeunes.
En tout cas,
un jeune sur deux, aujourd'hui,
veut se lancer dans le numérique
pour être indépendant,
pour avoir
une alternative
au salariat,
une alternative au niveau
des chances, tout simplement.
-Donc liberté.
Est-ce que c'est aussi la volonté
de gagner beaucoup d'argent ?
-Gagner beaucoup d'argent,
aujourd'hui, c'est possible.
Le numérique est
une opportunité
parmi tant d'autres.
Ca a créé
plus d'un million d'emplois
en 15 ans.
Aujourd'hui, 17 % des entreprises
sont dans le digital.
C'est bien,
mais c'est pas non plus
extraordinaire.
C'est 100 milliards
de ventes annuelles, en France.
C'est bien,
mais pas révolutionnaire,
en termes d'argent.
L'argent, aujourd'hui,
il est clairement ailleurs.
Il est aussi dans le numérique,
et c'est très bien,
mais il est aussi ailleurs.
-On va préciser les choses.
Il y a
une autre contradiction
que celle qui a été énoncée,
maintenant.
Si on prend
des grands dirigeants,
comme Elon Musk,
Jeff Bezos,
Mark Zuckerberg et leurs émules,
en France, en Europe
et ailleurs...
Ils nous ont seriné, à leurs débuts,
que c'était une révolution
dont le but était
de libérer les personnes
de leurs contraintes.
Or, ce qu'on voit,
aujourd'hui,
c'est que, en termes de libération,
les gens sont
en addiction.
Ils sont accros à des écrans,
des réseaux sociaux,
des croyances irrationnelles.
Comment expliquer
cette contradiction,
Charleyne Biondi ?
-Effectivement, les dirigeants
de la tech, aujourd'hui...
D'ailleurs, ça se voit souvent
dans leur slogan d'entreprise.
Que ce soit celui de Google,
"Don't be evil",
ou le slogan de Palantir,
"Make the world better",
c'est des slogans
très émancipateurs,
très...
Qui se fondent sur cette rhétorique
techno-utopiste qui est née,
comme l'a rappelé Daniel Cohen,
dans les années 60-70,
autour des premiers ordinateurs
et de ce mouvement contre-culturel.
Mais cette rhétorique
utopiste, émancipatrice,
liée à la technologie,
dans l'histoire
des techniques, c'est,
pour ne pas dire une anomalie,
une exception totale.
C'est-à-dire que, depuis Marx,
on a toujours considéré
que la technique,
c'était a priori...
L'appareil technique était
a priori
l'instrument des dominants
et le reste du monde
ne pouvait être
que soumis
à l'impératif technologique.
La technologie numérique,
parce que c'est la première
qui a offert
la possibilité d'être
à ce point manipulable...
Et pas tout de suite.
Les premiers ordinateurs,
dans les années 60...
Les manifestants
à Berkeley, en 64,
détestaient la technologie,
le numérique, les ordinateurs.
Ils manifestaient et comparaient
l'Etat dominant à un ordinateur.
C'est avec la "libéralisation"
du code informatique
et les premiers jeux vidéo
qu'on a commencé à comprendre
que l'informatique pouvait
être un outil pour l'individu
et plus pour des systèmes,
que ce soit
l'Etat technocratique
ou le capitalisme dominateur.
Cette rhétorique
a été hyper puissante.
Aujourd'hui, elle infuse
tout le marketing
et toute l'idéologie
sous-jacente
de ceux qui travaillent
dans la tech.
La dernière technologie numérique,
la blockchain,
quand on écoute
les idéologues...
Enfin, comment on appelle ça ?
Les évangélistes,
les crypto-évangélistes...
-Mais sur cette contradiction
de l'idée de liberté
qui devient un enchaînement,
vous pensez
qu'ils n'ont pas vu,
au début,
que les gens seraient
accros à ça ?
-C'est jamais possible
d'anticiper
tous les effets secondaires
d'une technologie.
On peut très bien s'imaginer
que les concepteurs...
Au départ,
on ne pouvait pas anticiper
les effets que la mise en pratique
d'une technique allait avoir
sur le monde social.
En revanche,
les algorithmes,
clairement, aujourd'hui,
construisent
les réseaux sociaux.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
l'économie de l'attention.
La logique économique,
derrière Google
et derrière les réseaux sociaux,
dépend
de l'utilisation fréquente
des utilisateurs.
-Permettez-moi de faire préciser
Jonas Haddad,
qui est avocat...
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez, vous,
de cette mise en cause
de la liberté ?
Parce que, finalement,
les gens qui sont sur les écrans
ne sont pas libres.
-Si on fait
de l'histoire du droit,
c'est des conceptions
très différentes de la liberté.
Ce que disent les autres invités
est assez sensé.
C'est une conception très américaine
de la liberté.
La conception américaine
de la liberté,
c'est considérer que
la liberté d'expression totale,
la liberté
capitalistique totale,
la liberté de faire ce qu'on veut
est une liberté.
Notre conception française
- dans les 1res années de droit,
on apprend ça -
est de dire que
la loi protège,
mais, finalement,
va venir nous libérer,
va venir réguler.
C'est une conception différente.
Avec le RGPD européen,
l'idée est de dire
que la liberté numérique
se crée par la régulation.
L'idée profonde américaine,
c'est que la liberté se crée
par toute la dérégulation.
Alors, à un moment,
c'est une dérégulation
woodstockienne,
soixante-huitarde.
Après, c'est une dérégulation
thatchérienne et reaganienne.
Là, c'est une dérégulation
de personnes,
et à la différence
de ce que vous disiez,
je ne pense pas
qu'ils ne soient pas conscients
de ce qu'ils font.
En tout cas,
les magnats de la tech
sont bien conscients
de ce qu'ils font
et ils veulent
imbriquer leur conception
de la liberté
sur ce qu'ils pensent.
Je vous donne
un seul exemple :
le métavers.
Dans la tête de Zuckerberg,
le métavers est une liberté,
car vous allez sortir d'un univers,
d'une société qui est difficile,
contraignante,
et vous allez les libérer
dans cet éden numérique.
-Mais qui est Zuckerberg
pour décider que le métavers,
qui virtualise
la relation sociale,
est une liberté ?
-Eh bien,
il est l'héritage
de cette double révolution,
de ce cocktail
décrit auparavant,
qui consiste à dire
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
des façonneurs
de notre société.
C'est à la fois
sa puissance financière,
mais aussi le fait de dire
qu'il est beaucoup plus légitime,
dans le nombre de personnes...
Il avait dit, une fois, Zuckerberg,
à un chef d'Etat :
"Vous savez, moi,
"j'ai plus d'adhérents
sur ma plateforme
"que, vous, de citoyens
dans votre pays."
-Passons, si vous le voulez,
aux questions
économiques, Daniel Cohen.
D'un point de vue économique,
vous connaissez très bien
ces fameux chiffres :
le 1 %
de la population le plus riche
qui concentre
un pourcentage très élevé
de la richesse.
Mais d'après vos études
à l'Ecole de Paris,
vous allez plus loin,
parce que vous dites que,
le 1 %,
c'est vrai, mais si on regarde,
non pas le 1 %,
mais les 20 %, en bas,
c'est-à-dire
une masse considérable
de Français, par exemple,
on s'aperçoit que
leur pouvoir d'achat
a augmenté, mais que leur part
dans la richesse nationale
a diminué.
Est-ce que vous pensez que...
La part de ces 20 %
les plus pauvres,
est-ce que vous diriez
que c'est une conséquence
de l'intelligence artificielle ?
En tout cas,
quel lien vous faites
entre l'intelligence artificielle,
le creusement des inégalités
et cette perte de richesse
des classes moyennes ?
Parce que, 20 % :
on est dans les classes moyennes.
-Oui, oui.
Alors, d'abord,
en effet, sur les chiffres,
pour rester aux Etats-Unis...
Ce mécanisme naît
aux Etats-Unis.
L'explosion des inégalités,
aux Etats-Unis,
est à couper le souffle.
Elle n'a aucun précédent,
dans l'histoire humaine.
Pour donner des chiffres
très simples à comprendre,
la part des 50 %
les plus pauvres,
donc la moitié
de la société américaine,
la moitié inférieure
est passée,
entre 1980 et aujourd'hui,
de 20 % du revenu total...
Les 50 % gagnaient
20 % du revenu total.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont descendus
à 10 % du revenu total,
donc leur part
relative
a été réduite de moitié.
La moitié
de la population américaine
ne gagne, aujourd'hui,
que 10 % du revenu total.
Au cours de la même période,
le 1 % le plus riche,
aux Etats-Unis, gagnait,
au début,
10 % du revenu total.
Aujourd'hui, il en gagne 20.
-Et en France ?
-C'est plus modéré.
Le 1 % est passé
de 8 à 12, en gros.
Pour prendre les Etats-Unis,
puisque c'est là que se joue
l'interprétation qu'on peut donner
de cette relation
entre les inégalités,
les années 80
de Thatcher
et ce phénomène numérique,
je crois
qu'il y a un lien étroit,
pas de causalité directe,
mais de mise en résonance.
Aujourd'hui,
aux Etats-Unis,
le 1 % le plus riche gagne,
en masse,
deux fois plus
- deux fois plus ! -
que les 50 % les plus pauvres.
Si vous voulez vendre un produit,
si vous vous adressez
au 1 % le plus riche,
vous avez face à vous
un pouvoir d'achat
qui est le double,
en masse
à dépenser,
de celui que vous auriez trouvé
chez les 50 %.
Le 1 et le 50 ont permuté
leur place.
-C'est bien,
mais quelle interférence
avec le numérique ?
-Je vous le dis.
C'est mon interprétation.
Ce qui s'est passé
au cours des années 80,
c'est un mécanisme dans lequel,
comme je le disais
sur l'interprétation qui a été faite
de Reagan et Thatcher
de ce moment historique
qu'on vivait...
Ca a été un moment
de déconstruction
des entreprises
telles qu'elles existaient
dans les années 50 et 60,
à savoir des mondes sociaux
tout en verticalité.
C'était donc à la fois
très inégalitaire,
du point de vue
des rapports humains
- on obéissait à quelqu'un
qui obéissait
à quelqu'un -
mais paradoxalement
très intégrateur,
en matière économique.
Au cours de ce qu'on appelle
les Trente Glorieuses,
tous les revenus augmentent,
en parallèle l'un à l'autre,
pour une raison
qui est que
tous les univers sociaux,
à l'époque,
appartiennent à des entreprises
qui ont les mêmes grilles
de salaires.
Quand un patron,
dans les années 60,
s'augmente de 10 %,
la femme de ménage
ou l'homme de ménage, tout en bas,
est augmenté de 10 % aussi.
Il y a une marche presque parallèle
de tous les revenus.
Ce qui se passe dans les années 80,
c'est que les femmes de ménage,
les services d'entretien,
les cantines, pour commencer,
sont sortis
de l'entreprise.
Le rapport de subordination
qui existait
au sein de l'entreprise
est transformé en un rapport
de donneur d'ordre
à sous-traitant.
On sort de l'entreprise
ce qui n'est pas considéré
comme essentiel au fonctionnement
de l'entreprise.
Tout ça est généralisé.
En fait, les entreprises
sont coupées en minces couches,
où ne restent entre elles
que des populations très homogènes
les unes aux autres.
Tout le personnel d'entretien,
tous les ouvriers sont
dans des équipementiers
qui ne sont plus
au coeur de l'entreprise.
L'Allemagne a externalisé
en ex-Europe de l'Est
un très grand nombre
de fonctions qui étaient
dans le système allemand.
Et on a des bureaux d'études,
des bureaux d'ingénieurs, etc.
Tous ces mondes clos
font vivre chacun et chacune
entre eux-mêmes.
La percolation de la richesse,
qui était inscrite
dans le fonctionnement
des sociétés industrielles d'hier...
-Des démocraties.
-...est mécaniquement empêchée.
Les entreprises ne sont plus
que des agrégats de personnes,
de personnels
parfaitement homogènes.
Je vous ai rappelé
les statistiques aberrantes,
aux Etats-Unis,
en matière d'inégalités.
La grande surprise a été
de découvrir que,
au sein des entreprises,
et non pas entre les entreprises,
les inégalités
n'ont quasiment pas changé.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'on est entre soi.
Dans une entreprise
où il n'y a plus
de disparités sociales,
les niveaux de revenus
restent les mêmes.
Avant,
quand un ingénieur avait
une idée géniale,
dans une entreprise,
tout le monde en profitait.
Maintenant, ça reste confiné
dans la sphère étroite
des membres
de cette entreprise.
Où vient le numérique ?
Eh bien, ce monde désarticulé
a un besoin social
considérable
de trouver la manière
de fonctionner
hors les murs traditionnels,
où je donne un ordre
à X, puis à Y et à Z,
qui redescend jusqu'en bas.
Ce monde a été inventé,
à la faveur
de toute cette déréglementation.
Ca commence
par des choses extrêmement simples.
Le fax donne un moyen
de donner des instructions
très précises
à des gens qui ne sont pas
dans votre entreprise.
L'essor d'Internet
- qui commence avec Arpanet,
comme on l'appelait,
dans les années 70 -
dans les années 90,
donne évidemment
le coup d'envoi à un monde
où les coûts de communication
sont complètement réduits.
Le lien entre les deux,
c'est juste ça.
Madame Thatcher disait :
"La société,
"je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire,
je connais des individus."
C'est exactement ça qui se passe,
à partir des années 80,
le numérique est
au service d'une société considérant
qu'il n'y a que des individus
qui tous se branchent
sur la Toile pour pouvoir
communiquer entre eux et l'effet,
qui est exactement ce qui est
inscrit dans la révolution
conservatrice des années 80,
c'est que ces individus,
soumis, dans cette plate-forme,
en compétition les uns
avec les autres, vous disiez
économie de la tension,
juste pour se faire
entendre sur Internet,
il faut un langage qui vous oblige
à vous faire reconnaître
en parlant plus haut,
plus vite que les autres,
en montrant l'innommable, bref,
on est dans une concurrence sauvage
pour se faire entendre.
Et tout ça ne prête pas
à la conversation
philosophique
au sens habituel du terme,
où y a un respect de la personne,
on écoute, on répond.
C'est juste impossible sur le Net
parce que la course
à l'intention
le rend impossible.
-Jonas Haddad,
vous êtes également un politique,
je crois que vous êtes élu
du conseil régional de Normandie.
Quand vous écoutez
ce que dit Daniel Cohen,
le numérique tue
la relation sociale,
bon, j'exagère en disant ça,
mais avec une espèce
de reproduction en quelque sorte
et d'accroissement des inégalités,
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait ?
-Beh, en fait, je pense que,
si je reprends
le titre de l'émission,
y a une forme d'aliénation,
mais qui est une aliénation,
une aliénation collective,
mais l'émancipation individuelle,
elle est présente
parce qu'il n'en reste pas moins
que le rêve
initial des créateurs d'Internet
et des magnats de la tech,
il peut aujourd'hui être
touché du bout du doigt.
On voit ce qui se passe
avec des femmes
iraniennes,
qui voient l'Occident,
par ce biais,
parce qu'elles ont
la connaissance Internet,
et dans certains pays
où des révolutions se sont mises
contre des tyrannies
par le biais d'Internet,
l'émancipation individuelle
de l'individu existe.
Après, que ça ait des conséquences
créatrices d'inégalités,
c'est du rapport économique.
Deuxièmement...
-Mais vous, vous acceptez
cette idée-là,
que ça crée, en tout cas,
ça favorise la disparité économique
et ça l'entretient,
en quelque sorte ?
-Ca l'entretient
mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle n'ouvre pas d'autres
potentiels.
On parlait des jeunes,
des nouvelles générations
qui considèrent par exemple
que l'instrument monétaire
n'est plus un instrument légitime,
ils vont dans les cryptomonnaies.
-On va en parler.
-Ils vont utiliser
une critique,
mais s'il n'existait pas
d'outil numérique pour,
ils n'en auraient pas
la possibilité.
Si je prends...
Je veux pas atteindre
rapidement le point Godwin,
mais on peut se poser la question
de savoir si un certain nombre
de génocides commis
l'auraient été
si y avait Internet ?
Là, ça ouvre une autre question,
la question
d'une troisième zone,
dont on a pas parlé, c'est l'enjeu,
la question asiatique.
On parle beaucoup
des Etats-Unis,
de l'Europe, mais aujourd'hui,
la puissance
de la tech asiatique
est équivalente...
-Oui, mais nous,
on fait pas de ségrégation,
on met en question
le numérique,
quelles que soient ses frontières.
-Pour vous dire que,
dans la conception asiatique,
la réponse
à votre question est négative,
car elle vient
complètement
aliéner l'individu.
-Margaux Klein,
on va passer à ce qui fâche,
c'est-à-dire le financier
et les monnaies
numériques puisque,
quelque part, c'est votre domaine,
avec le fonds Heritages.
On parle de bitcoins,
on parle de blockchain,
de cryptomonnaies,
leur efficacité vient
quelque part de leur anonymat,
mais y a des risques
d'évasion fiscale,
y a de la spéculation,
dernièrement,
l'actualité,
c'est l'effondrement de FTX.
Sincèrement, les cryptomonnaies,
c'est un progrès ?
-Déjà, pour revenir sur tout
ce qui est la grande question
des cryptomonnaies, l'anonymat,
le blanchiment d'argent,
ça existait bien avant,
on a pas attendu
les cryptomonnaies...
-Oui, la corruption date
depuis que le monde existe.
-On a pas attendu les cryptomonnaies
pour mettre ça en place.
Ensuite,
si on connaît bien
les cryptomonnaies,
on voit que c'est
impossible d'être anonyme
sur la blockchain.
Donc blanchir de l'argent
sur la blockchain,
il faut être ou stupide, ou naïf.
C'est beaucoup plus facile
de le faire sans blockchain.
Donc c'est déjà une question
qui est à mettre de côté.
Pour FTX,
c'est un très bon sujet,
c'est intéressant,
le cas de FTX,
parce que c'était
une plate-forme centralisée.
FTX, on peut le comparer
à une faillite bancaire,
comme on l'a vu en 2008.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que FTX était centralisé
et possédait les fonds
de ses clients,
donc ça n'a rien de blockchain,
ce n'était pas décentralisé,
c'était centralisé
et ils ont pris ces fonds
et les ont mal managés,
ils sont sous le coup d'une enquête,
on verra ce que ça donne.
Vous parliez de Heritages.io,
ça n'aurait pas pu se produire,
on ne possède pas
les fonds des clients,
c'est non-custodial.
-Mais vous placez les fonds
des clients ?
-Oui,
mais les clients
possèdent leurs fonds.
-Vous leur promettez la lune ?
-Non, ni la Lune, ni Mars,
comme Elon Musk,
ni des fusées qui atterrissent
toutes seules,
on leur promet simplement de pouvoir
investir à partir de 1000 euros,
sans passer par une banque,
en possédant leurs fonds
et en ne laissant pas leurs fonds
dans une plate-forme centralisée,
c'est simplement ce qu'on offre,
y a des rendements qui vont avec,
mais le progrès
technologique
est qu'on travaille
sans banque,
avec la tokenisation.
-Dites ce que c'est.
-La tokenisation ?
-Oui.
-Alors, la Suisse est un pays assez
avancé en matière de blockchain,
de plates-formes et de tokenisation,
et c'est très simplement
la fractionnalisation d'un actif,
donc comme une société,
par exemple,
on va diviser une société
en petites parties
et on va la rendre accessible,
à des montants plus bas
et plus attractifs pour tous.
On peut faire ça avec l'immobilier,
avec à peu près tous
les actifs qui existent.
-Alors, Charleyne Biondi,
convaincue ?
Vous êtes convaincue
par ce qui vient d'être dit,
y a pas de risque financier
avec les cryptomonnaies ?
-J'ai pas dit qu'il y avait pas
de risque financier, je pense que,
sur tout marché financier,
il y a des risques.
-Oui mais pas...
-D'où la rémunération.
-Voilà.
Donc il y a des risques,
ne disons pas
qu'il n'y en a pas.
-Mais FTX est un cas à part,
d'après ce que...
-Alors, bah FTX n'est pas
tout à fait un cas à part,
les faillites et les scandales
se sont un peu accumulés
dans le milieu de la crypto
ces derniers temps,
et l'effondrement d'un stablecoin,
une monnaie virtuelle
censée être stable,
qui l'était pas du tout,
mais effectivement,
FTX est pas exactement
un représentant idéal
de la technologie blockchain,
vous l'avez dit,
c'était une plate-forme
centralisée,
mais elle faisait bien
du trading en cryptomonnaie.
Mais c'est très important
de distinguer les deux,
c'est une confusion
qu'on fait systématiquement
parce que la blockchain est née
avec l'invention du bitcoin,
première cryptomonnaie,
mais la blockchain comme technologie
peut servir à plein de choses
qui ne sont pas forcément
les cryptomonnaies,
y compris dans le domaine financier,
où elle peut être utilisée
par des institutions financières
parfaitement régulières,
les banques qu'on connaît,
voire les banques centrales,
pour faciliter des échanges,
tout simplement des paiements,
de façon plus fluide
que les technologies
déjà numériques qui sont
utilisées aujourd'hui,
du style Switch et compagnie.
-Daniel Cohen,
en médecine,
y a ce qu'on appelle
la prévention.
En principe, la prévention
empêche la maladie
d'arriver.
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir
une prévention financière
pour qu'il y ait pas
de nouveau "Madox" ou de nouveau...
ce dirigeant de FTX ?
Est-ce qu'on peut
détecter ça un peu avant
pour que les gens
soient pas floués,
quelquefois,
de leurs maigres économies ?
-Toute l'histoire
des crises financières,
c'est toujours une course-poursuite
entre la régulation,
qui s'applique en général
à un état du monde T-1,
et des innovations qui visent,
là, je parle depuis
le début du 19e siècle,
toujours toutes à contourner
ces réglementations.
C'est toujours comme ça
que ça se passe
et je vois ça
comme une nouvelle étape.
Donc la question de la...
Dès qu'on fait appel
à l'épargne publique,
il faut un cadre réglementaire,
qui permet à des régulateurs,
des agences de notation,
mais surtout
à des réglementations publiques
de savoir exactement les risques,
au moins pour avertir les clients,
mais aussi pour voir
s'il y a un risque systémique
associé au fonctionnement
de cette collecte
de l'épargne publique.
C'est vraiment
aussi simple que ça.
L'exemple de FTX
est très représentatif,
vous avez raison de le comparer
à la crise des subprimes,
et c'est sans doute
pas la question blockchain,
mais on a un cas typique
d'un appel à l'épargne publique
qui n'a pas fait
l'objet d'une réglementation,
et le bonhomme était pas un Ponzi,
si j'ai bien compris,
mais il a pris
des risques insensés,
c'est toujours comme ça,
y a le moment
où vous avez un placement
et ce que les économistes
appellent
le "gamble for resurrection",
le moment où vous passez
sous la ligne de flottaison
et il faut prendre toujours plus
de risques pour s'en sortir,
avec cette espèce d'asymétrie
d'incitation...
-Parallèle avec Kerviel
et la Société Générale ?
-Non, c'est encore autre chose,
mais juste pour dire
que quand vous devez rendre 100
et que vous êtes descendu à 90,
vous êtes en faillite.
Donc passer de 90 à 80 ou 70,
ça n'a plus
aucune espèce d'importance,
vous êtes en faillite.
Par contre, passer de 90 à 180,
ça, c'est bien,
vous remboursez
et vous faites un profit.
Plus vous entrez en perte,
et sans être régulé,
plus vous êtes incité
à prendre des risques
pour essayer de vous refaire,
"gamble for resurrection".
C'est pour ça qu'il faut
des régulateurs,
qui disent : vous recapitalisez
ou vous sortez.
Au sein même des banques
ou des institutions financières,
on édit...
on veut chaque soir
connaître la situation
pour éviter
aux traders solitaires,
et y a quelque chose de Kerviel
dans cette histoire,
mais on veut absolument éviter
que le trader solitaire se retrouve
en situation de vouloir
prendre le risque de faire sauter
la baraque pour se refaire.
Tout ça s'appelle la réglementation,
la régulation,
et elle est indispensable.
Tout ce qui vise à la contourner,
pour moi, c'est un risque.
A petites eaux,
les gens avaient qu'à savoir,
mais arrive le risque systémique,
on l'avait vu avec les hedge funds,
LTCM avait failli provoquer
une crise financière,
qu'il n'a finalement pas créée,
mais dès que ça entre en résonance
et qu'on se rend compte que tous
les risques sont corrélés entre eux,
on risque la grande crise
comme en 2008.
Maintenant, juste un mot,
parce que c'est important,
par rapport
à la cryptomonnaie,
à la blockchain, etc.,
les banques centrales
réfléchissent
à la possibilité
de le faire elles-mêmes,
parce que c'est vrai
que c'est pratique, ces trucs,
mais je veux
de la réglementation aussi,
mais les banques centrales peuvent
émettre une monnaie certifiée
banque centrale,
pas de souci de réglementation
car elles connaîtront peut-être trop
tous les détails
de ce qui est détenu,
donc faudra des régulateurs
pour éviter à ce pouvoir
de s'exercer.
Le problème, si elles font ça,
mais pour moi, ça n'en est pas un,
c'est qu'elles détruisent
toutes les banques commerciales,
elles auront le monopole exclusif
de gestion des cryptomonnaies
et il faudra
un protocole permettant
de rendre ces fonds
aux établissements financiers
pour qu'ils bénéficient
de l'épargne.
On est à ce point d'hésitation
où on n'ose pas aller trop loin
dans le domaine public,
de peur de déstabiliser
le système privé,
mais comme la nature
a horreur du vide,
il faudra trancher.
-Margaux Klein,
une précision : le fonds Heritages,
vous êtes en Suisse,
vous y êtes parce que
les réglementations
sont moins...
rigoureuses,
ou vous avez choisi la Suisse
pour des raisons plus personnelles ?
Et est-ce que les réglementations
"sont-elles",
dans certains pays,
moins rigoureuses
que dans d'autres ?
-Alors moi, je connais l'Europe,
qui n'est pas un pays
mais une région
économique importante,
et la Suisse,
qui est le premier pays au monde,
actuellement,
à avoir autant légiféré
sur le domaine blockchain,
cryptomonnaie et tokenisation.
C'est les numéro 1,
actuellement.
Ils ont fait des lois très justes
et très sophistiquées,
donc la Suisse est aujourd'hui
le pays le plus régulé.
Donc c'est très lourd,
la réglementation,
en Suisse,
pour ces sociétés,
mais c'est possible.
Donc nous,
moi, je suis d'accord
avec Daniel Cohen,
on joue le jeu de la régulation
et de la réglementation, pour moi,
aujourd'hui, c'est obligatoire,
si on veut éviter des dérives
comme on a vu avec FTX ou autres
en début d'année.
La Suisse est très rigoureuse,
l'Europe aussi maintenant
avec la loi MiCA
qui arrive,
y a aussi Christine Lagarde
qui annoncé les CBDC.
-Et qui est
la présidente de la Banque
centrale européenne.
-Et qui a annoncé les CBDC,
qui est un projet
déjà lancé,
qui est déjà là,
elle a annoncé les trois grands
facteurs qui vont arriver,
donc c'est là, si on joue pas,
pour moi,
le rôle de la régulation,
ça vaut pas le coup.
-Jonas Haddad,
les services de renseignement
du numérique collectent
de nombreuses données.
On s'aperçoit que ces données
peuvent être là pour nous contrôler
et qu'il y a une espèce
de surveillance à grande échelle.
Est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que,
sur ce plan-là, y a un danger
pour la démocratie, y a un danger
pour la gouvernance politique ?
Est-ce que ce qu'on appelle,
pour simplifier,
ce néolibéralisme algorithmique,
il peut mettre en cause, finalement,
les questions de justice,
de liberté,
de gouvernance... voilà,
est-ce que...
-Vous savez, quand j'entends
ce genre d'affirmation,
ça me fait toujours penser
à ce que m'avait dit
un officier de police judiciaire
lors d'un premier contrôle,
il me dit : "tu sais,
les gens mettent sur Facebook
"100 fois plus d'informations
que ce qu'ils nous auraient donné
"si on les avait interrogés
comme policiers".
C'est-à-dire que, par nature,
les réseaux sociaux,
qui exposent ce qu'on est,
font qu'on donne beaucoup
plus d'informations
déjà de façon volontaire.
Donc le fantasme initial,
qui consiste à dire que
l'objectif de ces sociétés
serait le contrôle,
en fait, il est alimenté
par chacun d'entre nous,
qui "est" l'instrument
de son propre contrôle.
Ca, c'est un premier point.
Deuxième point,
on en revient aux différentes
conceptions des Etats qui vont
faire des régulations là-dessus.
Y a évidemment des Etats pour qui
c'est une source absolue
de contrôle,
on peut parler
du crédit social
à la chinoise,
qui va, si vous voulez,
par tous les éléments
que vous allez communiquer,
permettre de contrôler
votre conformité
avec les normes sociales édictées,
d'ailleurs en centralisant
l'ensemble des actes
de votre vie, vous savez,
y des plates-formes en Chine
pour votre paiement,
votre messagerie mais également
un certain nombre de sujets.
En France, en Europe,
c'est encore pas le cas, quoique,
avec Apple Pay, ça arrive,
mais globalement,
vous mettez des informations
sur Facebook,
vous payez avec une carte bancaire
et vous faites un tchat
sur du Whatsapp,
c'est pas encore
centralisé mais, en revanche,
ce qui est certain,
c'est que la conception même
des magnats de la tech qui ont
envoyé des milliards en recherche
pour permettre
le développement du numérique,
c'est la phrase des fondateurs
de Google, qui disent clairement,
en conférence de presse :
la vie privée
est quelque chose d'obsolète.
Et quand...
-Oui, mais de dire,
entre la vie privée,
c'est obsolète et permettre
à un Etat,
pour ne pas le citer, la Russie,
de faire de l'activisme
pour modifier le résultat
d'une élection,
on est là devant un système
de perversion démocratique.
-C'est un système
de perversion démocratique,
si vous voulez,
mais qui est quand même,
au fond, toujours
à l'initiative des Etats.
C'est toujours la conception
étatique qui va infuser.
La conception américaine
qui consiste à dire
que le plus important,
c'est la transparence plutôt
que la vie privée...
C'est en ça que, nous, Européens,
on a notre rôle,
le président dit souvent
"en Européens",
là, je trouve que ça a
un vrai sens, en Européens,
de dire ce qu'on a à raconter.
Dans la culture chinoise,
le collectif prime toujours
sur l'individuel,
donc le plus important est que
l'harmonie sociale soit présente,
quitte à regarder
dans la vie privée des gens.
Vous parliez de la Russie,
là aussi,
le concept global de l'Etat russe,
on le connaît,
est celui de la citadelle assiégée,
les Russes ont un concept global
consistant à se voir
comme toujours assiégés
donc s'ils veulent l'éviter,
ils peuvent le faire.
Alors, maintenant,
on doit en tirer des conséquences,
et notre conséquence,
c'est pour nos entreprises.
Très souvent, on dit qu'il faut
créer un Google européen,
ou un métavers européen,
et chaque fois, on y arrive pas.
Pourquoi on ne prend
pas ces vagues ?
Car au lieu de vouloir,
comme on le fait souvent en Europe,
générer par l'Etat des entreprises
qui vont avoir la capacité
de se projeter par rapport à ça,
on bride nos entreprises.
Et dans tous les autres pays,
on ouvre.
Et je termine
avec cette anecdote,
par rapport à votre question,
en Europe,
on a mis beaucoup de barrières
sur les questions de vie privée
et de données personnelles,
c'est très bien pour les individus,
mais il m'arrive
très souvent de voir
des entreprises qui viennent
me voir en disant que le RGPD,
"c'est très important,
pour nous,
"pour protéger nos données,
mais je dois t'avouer qu'on utilise
"des logiciels américains,
"asiatiques, israéliens,
"avec des conceptions
de la vie privée
"dans 'lequel'
y en a pas du tout".
Et donc notre volonté
de protection fait aussi que,
au final, on se met dans les mains
d'autres Etats qui ont
une conception différente
de la vie privée.
-Alors, Charleyne Biondi,
y a-t-il à votre avis quelque chose
à faire au niveau institutionnel
ou des Nations Unies
pour empêcher
tous ces dérapages
qui sont possibles par le numérique
et qui portent atteinte
à la gouvernance, la politique,
etc. ?
-Je pense que beaucoup de choses
ont déjà été faites.
La première fois,
pas exactement la première fois...
Si, la première fois qu'on a eu
les preuves que les Etats
avaient accès à nos données,
c'était grâce
à Edward Snowden en 2013,
on a commencé à parler
de surveillance de masse
et tout le monde a été horrifié
d'apprendre que les services
américains, la NSA
et une partie des services
européens pouvaient
collecter absolument
tout ce qu'on...
toutes les données personnelles,
toutes les métadonnées qu'on avait.
Entre-temps,
c'est ce qu'on appelait
le Snowden Paradox,
c'est-à-dire que les Etats
n'ont pas arrêté
ces pratiques de collectes.
Stratégiquement,
c'est impensable de se dire OK,
toutes ces données existent,
elles sont énormes,
on est en plein contexte
de lutte antiterroriste,
on va les laisser
aux entreprises privées
et nous, Etats,
on va faire différemment
notre renseignement.
Donc les Etats,
en France et aux Etats-Unis,
ont fait des nouvelles lois
pour encadrer
les pratiques de collecte
de leurs services.
C'est toujours un sujet,
le RGPD est
bien plus récent,
et je pense que la démocratie
libérale est
parfaitement armée
pour... contrer les externalités
de son économie.
C'est d'ailleurs le jeu.
-Oui, mais le KGB,
le KGB et...
les mafias russes ne sont pas...
en état de respecter,
en état
de respecter
ces choses-là.
-Effectivement,
mais dans ce cas, on passe,
on passe à un autre aspect
du conflit,
sur la scène internationale,
et effectivement,
la technologie fait partie
des nouvelles armes,
un nouvel instrument de conflit,
un nouvel enjeu des conflits
et là, dans ce cadre-là,
le numérique devient
un nouveau terrain et ça,
c'est tout à fait pertinent
et, encore une fois,
les Etats s'adaptent.
La France le fait au Mali,
on a eu plein de fake news
et d'ingérences
dans la campagne française,
les services français ont
été très rapides
à faire pareil au Mali.
-Margaux Klein,
sur cette question
de la surveillance,
dans les fonds que vous gérez
à travers le fonds Heritages, etc.,
vous êtes sûre que...
les informations
ne s'évaporent pas et que...
-Alors nous, déjà,
on a une obligation,
et on a choisi de la respecter,
d'être transparents
avec les autorités financières.
Tout ce qu'on fait d'un point de vue
financier est transparent.
On a émis des documentations,
tout est transparent.
-White paper, on appelle ça.
-White paper, prospectus,
une documentation
technique financière,
c'est pas mal
de documents transparents.
Au niveau des données clients, là,
on passe par un organisme régulé
au niveau
de la Confédération suisse
ou au niveau d'un Etat européen.
Donc là, on ne détient pas
les informations,
ces informations sont
chez un organisme agréé
qui va, bah, s'assurer
de la sécurité.
Et nous, on est tout en Suisse,
donc y a pas
d'Asie, d'Etats-Unis,
ou je ne sais pas quoi.
-Alors, cette intelligence
artificielle
fait penser aussi
à ce qui se passe en médecine
avec le transhumanisme.
Et le lien entre les deux
peut exister.
C'est-à-dire
est-ce que vous avez
conscience de cette chose-là,
que le numérique
et le transhumanisme
ont un peu la même
volonté de créer un homme nouveau,
pour parler,
avec grandiloquence,
comme Nietzsche ?
-Y a deux manières de voir
le monde dystopique
vers lequel on peut aller.
Le premier, c'est que le numérique
et l'intelligence artificielle,
avec toutes les données
dont on vient de parler,
vont être en pratique capables
d'avoir une information précise,
rigoureuse,
sur les huit milliards d'humains
qui forment
cette planète.
Y a pas d'obstacles
à ce qu'on sache tout
de vous, "on",
peu importe qui,
d'une certaine manière,
mais qu'une machine quelque part
sache tout de vous,
ce que vous êtes,
ce que vous faites,
où vous êtes
et où vous allez.
On a tous fait l'expérience
de faire un voyage de deux heures,
d'attendre deux heures en aéroport
de devoir passer la douane.
Dans un monde à venir,
on aura pas à passer la douane
car on saura exactement
qui vous êtes.
Déjà, ma fille habite à Londres,
dans les supermarchés,
c'est un peu à Paris
le dimanche,
mais vous entrez,
et vous avez déposé
votre carte de crédit
dans un club de fidélité
et puis vous prenez, vous partez,
y a pas de caisse,
on sait exactement : tiens,
la voici, elle prend, on repère.
On est dans un monde où,
d'une certaine façon,
l'intelligence artificielle va être
capable de gérer, optimalement,
les humains, dans leur corps,
quand ils se déplacent
dans les aéroports
ou dans les supermarchés,
dans leur carrière aussi,
ça a déjà commencé,
mais quand on est aujourd'hui
candidat dans une université
à travers Parcoursup,
y a pas d'humain derrière
à regarder votre CV,
c'est des algorithmes qui,
en fonction de critères,
vous recrutent.
Dans les recrutements, maintenant,
déjà, mais ça va certainement
s'amplifier,
vous pourrez avoir une position,
ici, pour faire ceci ou cela,
et rien n'interdit de faire
cette proposition à un million
de personnes car l'intelligence
artificielle va sélectionner
les dix candidats
que vous verrez à la fin,
évidemment, en face à face,
mais sur une base
peut-être planétaire.
Et on se projette encore plus loin,
y aura même pas besoin
de faire acte de candidature,
c'est déjà en pratique
en train de fonctionner
comme ça sur LinkedIn,
on viendra vous chercher.
Et même, faire acte
de candidature sera
une mauvaise chose,
ça voudra dire que
votre situation est mauvaise.
On viendra vous dire qu'on a vu
que vous avez passé des vacances
à Singapour, machin, et pourquoi...
Donc on peut imaginer,
sans être dans le transhumanisme,
juste dans l'intelligence
artificielle, qui,
en même temps
qu'elle crétinise l'individu
à travers ces pratiques
addictives sur les réseaux sociaux,
gère l'intelligence collective
du système sans que l'humain
soit en réalité en contrôle
de ce qui lui arrive,
on vous fait une offre, quoi,
d'où ça vient, et c'est comme ça.
Alors, la manière
dystopique de rivaliser
avec cette espèce de dualité
entre l'intelligence systémique
du côté de l'intelligence
artificielle
et l'abêtissement
du côté des humains,
c'est de dire que l'humain
peut se brancher des électrodes
pour être aussi puissant
que la machine,
c'est ce transhumanisme
dont vous parlez.
-Il nous reste si peu de temps,
ce qui vient d'être dit est
extrêmement intéressant,
mais on a très peu de temps,
peut-être brièvement, chacun,
que vous puissiez dire :
est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que ce monde virtuel,
ce monde numérique,
porte atteinte
à vos sentiments, à votre intuition,
à votre intimité,
Margaux Klein ?
-Il faut être très vigilent
à ce que l'humain reste
au centre de tout.
Donc il faut être très vigilant
à ce qu'on va demander
à l'intelligence artificielle
et de la façon
"dont" on va l'utiliser.
C'est un point de vigilance à avoir.
-Donc vous mettez
une frontière,
une barrière entre
votre activité
et votre intimité.
-Il faut vraiment
faire la différence.
-Jonas Haddad,
sur cette frontière,
elle existe aussi pour vous ?
-Je pense que le défi de toute
la génération qui arrive,
c'est d'éviter
la réification des humains,
c'est-à-dire que, en gros...
-C'est-à-dire transformé en objet.
-En chose,
voilà, qu'on ne soit
que le 1 et le 0
d'un algorithme global
et, pour ça,
y a deux choses
qui me semblent capitales,
pour garder
cet aspect humain,
un, c'est la culture générale
car, en fait,
même quand on dit
aux enfants d'apprendre
à coder, demain,
le code sera automatique,
donc même là-dessus, ils seront,
entre guillemets, remplacés,
seule la culture générale
permet une vision holistique.
Deux, je le réaffirme,
c'est le rôle des politiques.
On a parlé de ce que dit Zuckerberg
et de la conception
qu'il a de ce qu'il est,
si les politiques ne disent pas
qu'ils joueront à armes égales
avec des personnes
mues par des intérêts financiers,
assez vite,
ce sera les intérêts
financiers qui primeront.
-Tout à fait.
Charleyne Biondi,
quelle frontière
entre intimité
et l'activité numérique ?
-Je pense pas
que le numérique,
en dépit de toutes ses intrusions
dans l'intime et le privé,
transforme fondamentalement
la nature humaine.
Donc j'ai pas de crainte
qu'on perde notre libre-arbitre
par l'utilisation des technologies,
même quand on est
algorithmiquement manipulé.
En revanche, je pense que le sujet,
c'est de, effectivement,
réussir à retrouver
une attitude pro-active
face aux technologies
et à développer
cette réflexion,
une réflexion neutre
et non scandalisée par rapport
aux effets même négatifs de la tech
pour tenter de comprendre
comment ça nous transforme
et donc choisir
cette transformation numérique.
-Daniel Cohen, je voudrais terminer
par une dernière question.
Vous vous inspirez,
dans votre travail d'économiste,
d'économistes qui sont à la lisière
de la psychologie,
je pense à Stiglitz,
Daniel Kahneman, etc.,
qui a notamment
montré que, dans les discours,
y a un discours intuitif,
celui qui est immédiat,
et un discours analytique.
Est-ce que vous pensez
que l'algorithme aujourd'hui,
la civilisation algorithmique,
ça vise à une uniformisation et,
par conséquent, c'est la narration
humaniste qui est en danger ?
-Moi, je suis assez inquiet,
plus inquiet que vous,
parce que je crois
que nous sommes les héritiers
d'un humanisme,
qui naît au 11e, 13e siècle,
qui se développe
à la Renaissance et qui doit
beaucoup à la culture,
Gutenberg, de l'écrit,
où on peut
accéder au savoir
en lisant un livre,
sans être obligé de passer
par la médiation
d'un prêtre.
Y a un auteur, Caselli,
qui dit qu'un livre est un contrat
entre un auteur et un lecteur,
l'auteur donne le livre
mais ne se mêle pas de la manière
dont le lecteur va l'interpréter
et le lecteur, son contrat,
c'est qu'il lira les 300 pages
pour comprendre
ce que l'auteur a voulu dire.
Ca suppose du temps,
une distance critique,
d'avoir les quelques heures
pour lire le livre
et aller
du début à la fin.
Nous sommes malheureusement
dans une culture où la capacité
d'attention que propose le numérique
se réduit,
c'est la fameuse civilisation
du poisson rouge
dont parle Bruno Patino,
le fait que TikTok
l'emporte sur Facebook,
si je comprends bien,
c'est que, sur Facebook,
les vidéos sont
trop longues et que sur TikTok,
elles sont très courtes.
Et donc Kahneman distingue
un système 1 et un système 2.
Système 1, c'est celui
disons de la réactivité,
je me déplace,
je vois une pierre qui tombe,
je suis capable de me déplacer,
système 2, c'est celui de Gutenberg,
où on prend le temps
d'avoir une distance critique
par rapport à soi
et de faire le raisonnement.
Je crains malheureusement
qu'il y ait une bascule
de ces deux systèmes
et qu'on aille
vers un système beaucoup
plus émotionnel,
où le temps de la réflexion
devienne impossible,
bref, je crains,
pour dire des grandes phrases,
qu'on sorte
de la civilisation humaniste,
celle de Gutenberg,
et ça a commencé avec la télévision,
dans les années 60,
on voit cette distance
s'opérer par rapport
à la capacité de réflexion,
de lecture,
et je crois qu'on est en train
d'en sortir complètement,
les jeunes ont bien plus de mal
à rester concentrés sur un livre.
Moi-même, si je lis,
maintenant, j'ai compris,
je mets tous mes engins
dans une autre pièce, mon portable,
ma tablette, etc.,
parce que sinon, je sais que,
toutes les cinq minutes,
je vais être tenté de regarder
ce qui se passe et la lecture
devient presque plus pénible,
alors que je suis un grand lecteur,
si je suis à fonction...
Je crois que c'est Gérald Bronner
qui disait qu'un téléphone
qui sonne allume
les mêmes cellules nerveuses
que quand on appelle votre nom,
et donc que vous êtes
dans un rapport ombilical
à cette chose,
qui vous détourne du temps
de la réflexion.
Donc oui, je suis...
Alors la nature humaine,
après, c'est peut-être dans...
-On va terminer là-dessus,
est-ce que vous gardez
un temps pour le livre,
Margaux Klein ?
-Moi, j'adore lire,
j'ai fait des études littéraires,
donc je lis, et aussi,
il faut comprendre
la nouvelle génération,
peut-être y a un choc
des générations,
la nouvelle s'informe sur TikTok,
ça a aussi des conséquences,
mais c'est une façon
autre de lire,
car ils lisent aussi sur TikTok,
ils apprennent des choses,
ils consomment différemment
de l'information.
-Jonas Haddad,
toujours...
-J'ai une réplique qui me vient
de mon grand-père, Dieu ait son âme,
une fois où je lui avais dit :
mais ton téléphone sonne !
Il était en train de lire un livre,
il adorait lire, il m'a dit :
"Je ne suis pas domestique,
je ne réponds pas si on me sonne."
-Très bien, alors,
je vais vous donner
une brève bibliographie,
Daniel Cohen, d'abord.
Finalement, c'est une mise
en garde devant...
j'allais dire
ces progrès foudroyants
du numérique, c'est ça ?
-Une mise en garde,
mais j'essaie de faire le lien
entre l'attente que ça a généré,
vous parliez des femmes iraniennes,
y a ça, cette force anti-système
qui vient des années 60
est toujours présente
mais je pense qu'elle a été
profondément contaminée
par cette révolution
néoconservatrice qui fait
qu'on est des individus face
à un système plus fort que nous.
Mais c'est pas juste
l'individu et la machine,
faut vraiment retrouver
le sens des institutions,
pour ne pas être juste seul
face à ce choix.
On a besoin d'être réinstitués.
-Si vous permettez,
je ferai ce commentaire,
c'est que,
à une époque où l'économie
politique se vide
de son versant politique,
j'ai le sentiment que,
avec la psychologie, vous ramenez
à cette économie
politique pour la responsabiliser,
c'est bien ça ?
-J'adorerais que ce soit ça.
-Charleyne Biondi,
vous avez publié ceci.
On y apprend à décoder
ce qui se passe,
c'est bien ça ?
-Tout à fait, et pour revenir...
En fait, on partage le même constat,
je suis aussi d'accord, enfin,
le constat du livre,
c'est celui d'une transformation
d'ordre civilisationnel,
mais qui...
mais qui n'est pas
forcément négative.
-Alors, je conseille
à ceux qui ne l'ont pas lu
un ouvrage tout à fait actuel.
C'est écrit comme un polar
qui montre un peu
les déviations
et la fascination pour le numérique.
Je voudrais signaler
aussi celui-ci.
C'est lié à ce qu'on a dit
sur les dangers des écrans
pour nos enfants.
Et je voudrais signaler,
Margaux Klein,
vous avez publié ceci.
On a tendance à penser
à "Bonjour tristesse".
-C'est un clin d'oeil.
Je ne suis pas Sagan !
-Mais vous avez...
Vous y avez pensé ?
-Je le lisais,
quand j'ai écrit ce livre,
je lisais, je relisais
"Bonjour tristesse",
j'ai juste voulu ouvrir
et arrêter de diaboliser le mot
"richesse",
qui peut être multiple.
-Jonas Haddad,
vous avez un livre
à nous proposer ?
-Non, une anecdote
sur un bouquin
que j'ai écrit en 2014,
que j'avais appelé "Droite 2.0",
que j'avais proposé à des politiques
et je vous cite
ce qu'ils avaient dit,
avec mon co-auteur :
"Oh, c'est des trucs
de jeunes start-uppers,
"le numérique n'aura aucun
"impact sur la société."
-Vous voyez comment
on peut faire
des prévisions fausses
qui rejoignent ces idées fausses
dont parlait Spinoza
et qui empêchent
la puissance d'agir.
Merci mesdames,
merci, messieurs, d'avoir
participé à cette émission,
je remercie l'équipe de LCP et,
avant de nous quitter,
je vous suggère cette pensée
de Serge Tisseron :
"L'instinct surexposé menace
la construction du moi."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA